ces jeunes bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
vient de voir cette petite vidéo de
donald trump qui affirme qu'il va
beaucoup mieux
ces dernières heures il ya eu une sorte
d'hypocrisie au yo-yo autour de l'état
de santé du président américain
est-ce que voilà c'est une opération de
communication de se mettre en scène de
montrer que l'on va mieux alors que l'on
est toujours attendue du coït 19 c'est
important pour donald trump aujourd'hui
d'être là bien sûr c'était un combattant
c'est pour ça que c'est les gens qui
l'ont voté pour lui lille ont voté pour
lui c'est un combattant qui se laisse
pas faire on l'a vu depuis trois quatre
ans soit quatre années
bientôt quatre années et cie main ce qui
m'a vraiment choquée aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils ont fait un conférence de presse
à la maison blanche
donc pas avec tron et il ya personne qui
lui a demandé qui a demandé quand est il
de mélanie tron personne n'était pressé
pour sa part ça parce que tout est
politique évidemment et rien
d'humanitaire
maintenant s'ils trompent veut aller à
qui il veut a dit que c'était pas le
coran le virus est exagéré ont la preuve
c'est que au début de l'épidémie
souvenez vous il ya on parle et où on
avait toutes ces infos et toutes ses
oeuvres
c'est l'info qui disait genre l'épidémie
a maintenant est un 33 mille personnes
en 3000 morts en italie où les espagnols
ces derniers temps ces dernières 24
heures ils ont perdu 3 164 âme on avait
ça sans cesse et bien c'est un faux les
a plus et donc ça veut dire c'est bien
sûr les médias s'il y avait des morts il
en parlerait maintenant on en parle plus
du tout au danemark
ils ont dit il y avait trois cent
soixante quatre vingts personnes qui
avaient pris qu'ils avaient de nouveau
levé rice et et les deux morts donc
c'est exact contrairement à ce qu'a dit
votre la personne qui est intervenu et
tout a tout de suite tout à l'heure là
c'est vraiment exagéré ce qui se passe
je vous rappelle que
personne dans aucune ville dans aucun
pays soit la france les états unis ou
n'importe quel pays n'a vu des morts
dans les rues personne la vie des gens
dans le métro qui ce qui était malade
qui se prennent le coup le la gorge qui
s'écroule en train de vomir du leur sang
noir on n'a rien vu de tout cela
la chose qui se passe maintenant c'est
que les gens c'est que les gens s'ils
attrapent la maladie sont malades pour
opus de semaine voire trois
c'est comme tom hanks ou madonna ou le
prince charles ou albert de monaco voir
greta thun bern
voilà où silvio berlusconi est après
deux semaines de deux trois semaines ils
sont de nouveau sur pied
je vous rappelle que le mot quarantaine
signifie 40 jeux 40 jours et pas un de
plus en en gommant ou en 2d c'est
s'isole en isolement
c'est seulement pour les malades et que
de trois semaines ça fait 21 jours donc
nos ancêtres quand ils ont été dans leur
sagesse
ils ont bien vu ils ont bien dit et ils
ont été du coup ils ont péché du côté de
la prudence ils ont dit 40 jours c'est
ça suffit revenir de disque dur une
autre chose en français n'existe pas de
mots qui s'appelle la glace en
quarantaine ou les 261 notre sujet c'est
donald trump en fait moi j'aimerais vous
poser des questions par rapport aux
états unis on sait que le président a du
retard dans les sondages on est en
pleine campagne
il a d'ailleurs dû annuler notamment son
meeting en floride
c'est la raison pour laquelle il veut
retourner à la maison blanche justement
se relancer dans la course et continuer
cette campagne
puisque joe biden est en train de
prendre de l'avancé 1 c'est vrai c'est
un g10 est un combattant c'est un
travailleur il n'y a rien de mieux que
le travail contrairement à certaines
personnes sur la gauche mais c'est sûr
que il regarde les sondages
cela dit on se souvient très bien qu'en
2016 hillary clinton allait gagner
le bureau ovale la maison blanche
s'étaient tous les sondages le disent et
et j'étais à paris j'étais à la maison
de la radio
et j'étais aussi étonné que les autres
que tous les os les plus les peu de
républicains qui étaient là et aussi
étonné que les démocrates qui pleut qui
ont commencé à pleurer vers 4 5 heures
du matin merci beaucoup en tout cas
monsieur ericsson d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes chef
déjà fumé diar des républicaines ça une
france